the summer wildfire season is
intensifying with nearly a dozen new
fires reported
just yesterday alone so far this year
we've seen more than 33 thousand
wildfires across the country
that's the most in a decade the national
interagency fire
center says the fires have burned two
million acres that's an area larger than
the state of delaware
the biggest and most dangerous fires are
all in the west
lilia luciano reports on the wide
ranging effort to control them
from california and washington to idaho
and arizona
more than 14 thousand firefighters are
battling to contain
more than 60 wildfires out west oregon's
bootleg fire is now the nation's largest
growing to over 200 thousand acres and
forcing hundreds from their homes
it was hungry it was mean it was ugly
and it was right there where we could
watch it in california crews on the
front lines of the beckworth fire
north of lake tahoe captured these
dramatic images
of flames closing in near yosemite
national park the river fire continues
to spread
across two counties during peak tourist
season
she's really high stress amy stevens
manages a bar
and restaurant in the nearby town of
owani are you adapting to the frequency
of these fires in the longer heat
absolutely it is becoming a new normal
it's been so frequent and every year
it's like when is it going to start not
is it going to start
the only power we have is to go go go
veteran firefighter zachary resnick is a
squad leader for the big bear hot shots
a highly skilled hand crew that responds
to some of the biggest
and most dangerous fires we caught up
with the group as they wrapped up their
first day on the river fire
what concerns you the most about the
fires right now the lack
of resources and it's not because we
don't have
a ton of firefighters in california
there's just that many fires
there are several fires burning within
yosemite national park
what we know is that those were started
by lightning strikes
and park officials tell me that they are
very small and they're currently not
threatening
any park areas where visitors can visit
or park
services adriana all right lilia stay
safe thank you so much